Samuel leaves here and on this video
we're going to be doing a social
experiment around property investing
being successful and what people think
of that so just a little bit of
backstory when I first wanted to become
a property investor I was 17 years old I
had 3,000 pounds saved from paper
round's for a kid and I got around good
people and I put that three thousand
pound towards education and by the age
of 21 so for years I accumulated over a
million pound property portfolio and was
completely financially free right now
I'm 26 I'm a multimillionaire I've got
four successful companies all around
property and Hazel's going to happen in
this experiment so I'm gonna go to this
website Yahoo Answers and ask the world
a question and I'm gonna ask them
pretending to be 17 years old again and
I'm gonna say I'm 17 years old I want to
be a property millionaire by 21 what
advice would you give me and just see
what people say okay so I'm 17 years old
3000 pounds
[Music]
okay so Thomas by the waiting game I'll
let you know the results very shortly
[Music]
it's now a few weeks later and I've just
happened to go onto Yahoo Answers I'm
shocked at some of the answers so the
sort of question was I'm 17 years old
I've got 3,000 pounds saved from pay per
ounce and I want to be a property
millionaire by the age of 21 what advice
would you give there's a fair question
yeah that's the kind of question that if
the say for 3,000 pounds of paper
anything good on your kid hears people's
responses so the first one my advice is
to quit dreaming second one it won't
happen in four years I advise you
rethink your goals and set them towards
something that is realistic next think
smaller property prices are ten times
that or more stop wasting your time it's
not happening on this one someone said
lower your lower your expectations stay
in school
move to another planet is not happening
on this one being a property millionaire
by 21 just isn't going to happen
in this one here which has been voted as
a best out supply many people says it's
totally impossible quit dreaming
this is very this is what the this is
what the world are saying this is and
people that go on you answers they tend
to be pretty qualified people at work
I think the bright smile is these guys
honestly think they're talking to a 17
year old with a big dream it's just
dreams are good to have provided you
realize their dreams not reality
what advice get real you're a 17 or
Bieber boy and you want to own your own
property with 1 million in four years
sorry that is not going to happen and
then it gives me a long explanation
explaining mathematically why it's
impossible
when Gees make sure you don't end up in
prison I don't think you can do that
stop dreaming face facts it's not going
[Music]
the funny thing is is that it actually
did happen and not only did it happen
but I want to do a lot more than that
but it kind of pains me just to think
that there's kids out there who are a
driven who've got great goals realistic
goals and they want to be successfully
property they want to be financially
free and the world is not just one or
two haters but the world will tell you
that's not possible
stop dreaming go back to school it's a
complete joke so I just want to say
there if you are watching this and if
you are 17 years old or if you're in a
job and you've been told
quit dreaming property thing is too good
to be true
you know what just remember they're the
Jokers keep doing what you're doing
I heard a story one time of it was a few
monkeys in a cage and the top was open
he was dead easy for the monkeys to jump
out of the cage but what would happen is
there was a guy standing there with this
big water hose and every time one of the
monkeys would go to jump up the guy
would spray the monkey and it would be
soaked and it would fall down to the
ground and what would happen is they
realized that you just you just can't do
that you know if you go up you get
sprayed and then they added in an
additional monkey into the cage with no
hose pipe and that monkey went to jump
out of the cage and the other few
monkeys
no no you can't do that poured the
monkey down because they were programmed
that when you go up you get sprayed so
they pulled this monkey down and the
other monkey was not okay they all
pulled me down therefore it's obviously
not possible and then they they slowly
remove some of the original monkeys and
we placed it with new monkeys until they
had three or four new monkeys in the
cage that have never been sprayed but
they never went up and if anyone went to
the other keys would poke the monkey
down and I feel like right now we're
living in generation where they're being
people hundreds of years ago who have
failed and then from generation to
generation to generation that we just
programmed to don't even try so you know
I'm gonna do in Orleans gonna learn
about this and this has been a little
bit of a rant but I'm feeling pretty
annoyed right now at the comments I'm
also feeling pretty like yes stuff you
the fact that they all said it can't
happen and I've done that and beyond
stop stop them but we really shouldn't
be wanting to be successful from a place
of wanting to prove ourselves but next
week either they do a video and on the
video I answer my own question on the
other answers properly I'm gonna tell
you if you're seventeen you've got three
thousand pound saved I'm gonna give you
some practical advice that you can
follow and that will help you to
becoming financially free and a property
millionaire I'm gonna end this video but
I say next week I'm gonna do a party to
this I'm gonna answer my own question
and I'm gonna give you some actual sound
advice not stupid advice I'm so fed up
with the negativity that's gone in the
world that's why I do this channel I do
this channel to show you one that it can
be done and to to teach you guys how to
become financially free through
properties I hope it's inspiring stay
tuned subscribe below and you'll see a
lot more and I look forward to catching
up with you next week god bless
if you want to take it seriously if you
want to achieve something in life out of
state action there is no better time
than now I mean a year later from now
you're going to be regretting that you
didn't take action and you're back so if
any one highly encourage you just do it
there is literally no nothing holding
back you jump
[Music]
you